[Musique]
ça c'est le prozac
solitude stress peur c'est le nouveau
quotidien de nombreux clients de cette
officine marseillaise ces derniers mois
ce pharmacien a vu ses ventes
d'antidépresseurs explosé de plus de 60%
il ya une manif de quelques dizaines de
personnes
une manif contre vous il y avait que 3
ou regarde on voit les images de
plusieurs cars de crs également et de
police par donkey qui se sont mis devant
pour protéger le palais viviane parce
que des gens disent qu'ils ont envie de
manifester contre vous contre ses
privilèges
le monde s'en fout par contre le monde
ne se fout pas et ça c'est très
important qu'il y avait eu des mises aux
hommes politiques et des membres du
gouvernement
alors je vais encore une fois démentir
il n'y a jamais eu de politique dans ces
soirées dans cette soirée soit j'en ai
fait une seule c'était pas une soirée
est à une conférence napoléonienne pour
la réouverture du palais d'hygiène à
partir du mois de mai du mois de juin
ils disent qu'ils avaient un ministre
dans cette soirée
alors effectivement il y avait un homme
politique d'accords d'après 16 ans est
un homme politique sortant aux policiers
que moi shenaz donc savait pas c'est un
ministre ou pas non mais bon on vous a
dit provoqué ce qu'on vous a demandé à
d'autres serveurs on sait brief un petit
peu ouais et on nous a dit attention à
cette table à c'est un homme politique
donc faites attention à la manière de
servir à la manière de parler mal à la
ministre merci nous accueillir dans
votre ministère on est très fier d'être
là dans top chef
moi je suis très très heureuse de vous
accueillir dans ce beau ministère de la
transition écologique qui est le
ministère on essaye de faire bouger les
choses et j'ai l'impression que vous
aussi vous essayer de faire bouger les
choses
c'est un homme politique en activité en
actionnant ministres en activité à la
twitter c'est la ministre un homme
politique d'accord quand je veux dire
simplement c'est qu'il n'ya plus il n'y
a pas eu de ministre d'accord il n'y a
pas eu deux hommes politiques et que
c'était uniquement une soirée afin de
subvenir en parla pour aura la
réouverture de ce club du palais
vivienne dans un mois ou dans deux mois
quand le gouvernement aura décidé de
rouvrir les vannes et le business peut
pas vous dire autre chose que c'est une
personne qui a les cheveux gris
aucun n'a pas quarante minutes d un
policier
qui en décembre quand même du
gouvernement je pense pas d'accord du
gouvernement donc voilà donc c'est un
milito gouvernement n'aura pas donné de
nom ici paris j'étais dans une spirale
voilà mais honnêtement franchement cc
c'est un certain c'est un verre d'eau
dans une tempête là vous êtes un bouc
émissaire dans cette affaire ah ben
alaoui complètement en plus j'ai
l'impression qu'on s'est vraiment bien
foutu de moi quoi cette scène que vous
allez voir a eu lieu le 29 janvier
dernier aux alentours de 22h alors le
cabinet de la ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur frédéric vidal a confirmé
l'authenticité de cette vidéo
voilà on les voit de loin c'est une
voisine qui filme déclarant qu'il
s'agissait d'un moment de convivialité
entre également dans l'abord du bailly
dans la fête à la limite à la boîte gay
du monde dont 6 sur celle là mais grave
et non mais elle a traversé les
générations comme une armoire normande
quoi mais bon alors je m'assure que
jérôme arnaud mais non mais elle a
traversé tout on connaît celle à la
crise aura bien profité aux plus riches
si jeff bezos le patron d'amazon est
toujours numéro 1
les 20 premiers de ce classement ont vu
leur fortune augmenté de 62 % en un an
chez des français aussi c'est la fête
même s'il n'y a pas de changement dans
le haut du classement avec bernard
arnault le patron de lvmh
toujours en tête une nouvelle entrée à
la 23e place est tout de même très
remarquée celle de stéphane bancel
le pdg de modern art société américaine
en pointe dans la course au vaccin anti
qu'ovide semences avait fait bon vivre
[Musique]
seulement l'affairé est seulement c'est
ça les fait bouger
tu te rends bien compte quand même que
c'est un problème dans ta vie sociale se
moque c'est sûr mais qu'est ce qui fait
qu'on n'arrête pas de tablier comme ça
si tu en as conscience parce que
j'aimerais qu'on me voyais et je vais
faire une télé réalité
que tu vas y être repérés pour faire de
latéralité c'est une chose est pas
obligé d comme ça c'est pas ça qui va
tuer parce qu'il ya beaucoup de filles
comme ça t'as pas besoin de tout ça je
sais pas à quelques semaines
l'émission a transformé ces inconnus en
star la chanson qu'ils ont écrites
pendant leur enfermement est enregistrée
dans le confessionnal lofteurs up hendon
devient le tube de l'été avec près d'un
million d'exemplaires vendus à ceux dont
on se rappelle ses lacets la fameuse
piscine donc évidemment ça n'a rien à
voir sauf que la vénus de botticelli
quand il sort comme ça nutt son
coquillage ça change l'art de la
représentation ce qu'on n'avait jamais
représenté une femme comme ça et elle
même elle est mise en situation de
fragilité est donc assez delsinne
finalement inconsciemment rejoue ça et
on voit que la célébrité n'est pas
quelque chose de toujours marrant non
plus on se tient les nains comme ça et
on invoque le saint-esprit tous les
soirs et des fois il nous arrive comme
les jeux blancs et tout mais c'est vrai
alors même si j'ai montre moi comment tu
fais d'accord tu as les mains comme ça
ok bon on décide notre père dans notre
tête
kate on perd notre personne a crié
tellement connectés que ça arrive combat
gamme peugeot puisque la par le simple
fait d'être dans cette cloche là est
bien avec ce carton perforé relâche dans
une cloche c'est impressionnant non
monsieur grande forme aujourd'hui
la phrase qui te fait du bien et que tu
te répète au quotidien soit belle et
rebelle que moche et aux moches là pour
moi c'est vraiment laid back
c'est un bonheur de servir au mieux
cabinet wan dans la tête
chaque lofteurs reçoit même à disque de
diamant pour marquer le coup donc j'en
ai un exemplaire aussi en bonne place
wen en même temps c'est à dire on l'a
mis dans nos toilettes mais c'est un bon
endroit aussi les toilettes parce que
c'est un endroit agréable on voit tous
les jours